what's going on citizens of the reject
Nation we are about to do a first time
watch of Batman under the Red Hood now
even though I'm very familiar with under
the Red Hood I read those Comics well
over a decade ago and I have somehow
never seen this incredibly rated movie
Greg thought it'd be fun to pair me up
with John today because as far as I know
you know the character but not like his
machinations he haven't read the comics
you haven't seen the movie and I have a
red hood yes because this is your
marketing this is this is a branding
situation yeah exactly no I know the
basics of the character pop culture
osmosis so we're both about to watch it
for the first time so please do leave a
like leave a comment let us know what
you thought of this video and as always
if you want to do a full length sync up
with your own copy watch long head over
to the real rejects patreon page where
we've got a one-to-one setup join us for
the whole Adventure the whole journey
now before going into this I did want to
mention the channel geek that is
g-i-q-u-e I've got an exclusive video
over there actually two and so does Greg
now what geek does is these incredible
one minute character videos everything
from the pop culture impact to their
origin stories you can really get a lot
of data from this site all at once and
it's got content from a wide variety of
creators and that's why we really wanted
to shine a spotlight in them today so
not only is it a great place to get
extra geeky content but if you're a
content creator yourself and you're
trying to get some more exposure you can
also potentially get paid to produce
these one minute shorts I've got a
couple of videos over there I dive into
the Red Hood himself because I love this
character but also wanted to give some
love to one of my favorite characters of
all time Miguel O'Hara Spider-Man 2099
and Greg's got some mysterious video
over there that he won't tell me what it
is but I'm gonna look at geeked and I'm
gonna find out so it'd be great if you
guys could check out geek we really want
to shine a spotlight in them I love what
they're doing now not only for the geek
Community but also for creators it is a
great communal experience over there
sharing knowledge and exposure for
creators and geek them alike so we are
thrilled to be partnering with them as
we dive into Batman under the Red Hood
[Music]
I like these Vibes starting well I'm
very excited yeah this I've heard is one
of the best DC animated films and DC is
usually that's their jam
I should never have Allied myself with a
Madman
he has the boy
oh oh no Robin
that looked like it really hurt
Thriller I mean obviously obviously the
Riddler you can start this thing with a
crowbar clay face all right what hurts
more
a
okay or B
forehand ah
this is pretty intense a little
laugh I think you may have a collapsed
lung that always impedes the oratory
[Laughter]
oh man he won't make it there in time
nah Batman's always on time like a
wizard please tell the big man I said
hello
[Laughter]
whose voice yeah it's a different joke
in the dark
use those acrobatic skills
there's those contortions
dude the bike looks rad
oh
you knew it knew this was coming Pete
and in the comics this was all by a fan
vote Jim Starlin gave fans the option to
call a number to vote with a robin lived
or died and fans voted to kill Robin and
it was a tight vote it was like down to
56 or something insane but but they
killed Robin via 1-900 number you are
monsters you
Jesus
Jason rip Jason Todd anti-opened the Red
Hood movie yeah that was pretty chilling
that was very cool I'm guessing Bruce
Greenwoods are Bruce
Jensen Ackles yeah I imagine he's a red
hooded
so excited
John DiMaggio is he our Joker I could
hear that I can't hear his voice Timbre
in there and NPH who's he gonna be
oh look at that too that's gorgeous
Gotham City
city is a sewer that needs its cover
replaced
it's very shiny but you know off kilton
like Gotham it's what underneath that
defines you God I love this you should
make a list video of the best Batman
stories that don't start with the words
Gotham City that's a top one
I like the blend of CGI and hand-drawn
animation so far yeah it's well chosen
gorgeous a nice blend of the classic
animated series some comic input this is
a beautiful Gotham there's nothing like
an animated movie Gotham yeah truly
wasn't my meat
how the hell with this I'm going
your brain donors want to hang around
sit down
brain donors movie reference yeah who
the hell are you smoking
not Batman
I'm offering you morons a deal you go
about your business as usual but kick up
40 to me
in return you will have total protection
from both black mask and Batman but you
stay away from kids in school yards but
why the hell should we listen to you
that's my workout bag
gains
black mask
those are the heads of all your
lieutenants
you want to see what I can get done in a
whole evening
I'm not asking you to kick in with me
I'm telling you
oh
that's a triple tap
to eat 40 works for me good intro for
the Red Hood that's great just an Ackles
sounds younger which would make sense
but still it's taking me back you asked
me what 12 13 years ago yeah just grab
them up screw it just go get us out of
here
I think I lost him you think I lost them
I think he lost I think you lost him
no
you're anything but good
oh mother right
who are you working for nobody lie to me
again and crashing into a wall head-on
will be the least painful activity of
your evening
oh
oh what is that your cargo
but you weren't doing nothing it's
called Amazo a highly Advanced
cybernetic Android equipped with the
ability to absorb the power of
superhumans what kind of superhumans
all for one
Pack's quite the punch for a toaster on
steroids huh
hey
Nightwing yeah
oh nice
foreign
yeah buddy
get the higher ground
no he could fly
oh
I wouldn't be offended by a few
suggestions he has the same weak points
as a human being got it kick him in the
nuts eyes got tears
man we didn't Nightwing in a movie so
bad Nightwing's awesome it's one of the
few like remaining characters we really
haven't seen you yeah
yeah nice I don't think
eyes it's gonna hurt him oh that's C4
come on Nightwing
oh yeah
it was smart to use Amazo like I I like
the blend of different villains because
like I don't think of a meso as a Red
Hood story but now we have them together
oh cool
Let It Go Right
for the Red Hood we don't have any
choice
wow the shots came from the rooftop a
sniper a good one
yeah
excellent deduction Robin see him
nightmare yeah oh look at this one
building and find him
hey wait
Batman's sort of a dick
oh that like heat Ripple yeah the really
really smart use of foreground
background with the animation
see he doesn't use guns he uses things
and I was about to say if you like if he
if he just shoots the car he's gonna
like Massacre this tunnel in the process
yeah the smart
[Applause]
[Music]
it's all part of the Hood's plan though
I got you right where he wants yeah
at a chili Factory delicious it's gonna
be ace chemicals because that's what I
assume they'd tie in
wait
I'm not a truck I swear
oh no
The Riddler
his origin story Edward Enigma favorite
character
in a way Batman this was the sight of
your first great failure maybe your
greatest
but certainly not your last right ah
memories oh
spicy boots dang almost became the
Batman who laughs just then how many
times the ace chemical plant is to float
up the ace chemical plant must be
impossible to ensure that's my next list
how many best Ace chemical explosion and
that's why there are no competitors in
town it's not worth it it's the only
chemical place
yeah
several criminals have utilized this
Persona one criminal of particular
interest though huh but he's locked up
it's a fun way to tell a lot of story in
a couple seconds
that's right man yeah exposition
maybe we should go for a visit
could you just once
[Music]
I feel like that was an mph ad-lib I
wonder like how much they let him just
play yeah it's like I'm just sticking in
a wide shot you know
what do you know about it
that he has horrible taste when I wore
that number it was classy more flashy
Mater D than motorcycle fetish
better off than his replacement right
even tougher making with the yucks when
your worm food
good clue
you really think I would stir up so much
trouble and not make sure you knew it
was me that is a solid Point I've always
left the Joker in so many ways is
smarter than Batman
you idiots know how many bitters I had
on a meso a list of puppet dictators and
psychos as long as my arm Millions shot
right to hell and whose money
money your money
my money oh yeah
who blows the damn robot's head off
I could have at least sold it for scrap
Batman kept it yes Batman likes to keep
things
glass man collects
penny a dinosaurs okay really it's all
bought and paid for so this is strictly
a delivery not a buy but in view of
recent events I've taken the liberty of
doubling the security detail and
switching the drop spot that sounds like
a plan
I like how the audio engineer like mixed
those like that one line and three
different audio Styles so it gave it
more like depth
[Music]
okay I won't be staying that long
you know what I missed most about
running with you the toys
not done you want to dance let's dance
[Music]
okay I'll just take care of this I like
the slight Odd Couple humor between the
Nightwing
oh no oh
cool awesome
oh my God
Red Hood plays video games that's how to
use props well
I love how many low-flying blimps Gotham
has too way more than all the United
States the blimp ratio much higher
[Music]
nah don't don't discount yourself
I love how many explosions he is
throwing at him
yes like the ultimate clue hidden in
plain sight he's been trained and
trained well like right there that he
sliced that cable off his ankle before
it went taut you don't just do that oh
wait ow Alfred take him home Bruce I can
still help
you already have
thank you
[Laughter]
this is like me and Greg in the office
thank you thank you okay
hobbles out makes some thumbnails
oh here we go
[Music]
you haven't lost your touch bro
[Laughter]
it's funny I probably maybe have
questioned that before but now I know
that software exists yeah we live in a
scary time yeah I've used that software
[Music]
oh the memory
foreign
like the the way the the revealing stuff
hey it's a joke hey it's the curve
finally
Nemesis it's over Riddler
[Music]
nice what's green and purple but covered
in red and yellow
ouch
when I land on your sorry butt don't
move we're up you're white shoot me
oh nice nice
Robin I didn't think I had to prop up
some pillows before I took him out
he would have talked but you put him
into shock that was dumb
but he deserved it
I like how quickly they were able to
summarize like even just the shock like
the the ability of to get what they
needed out of them and like why
aggressive Vengeance doesn't work
because that even like all the people
that think Batman should use guns like
there's all this summarizes all the
reasons you have to have a skill
[Applause]
foreign
hood is that right
The Rusty Nail you're a club owner and
some big damn drug dealer in the East
quarter right you stupid bags of
manners fatty I don't care who takes
care of you you watch your mouth you
don't gotta body shame the guy
it's the real villainy but on top of all
the things you're doing to them
was sending your boss a message
oh
[Music]
what's the message
a simple one actually
want to guess what it might be
they looked bulletproof yeah
[Music]
even know who I am
oh
no you four of all this power and all
you do is it is kill for money from what
I hear we've got that in common
you heard wrong
oh
yeah
oh the fight hasn't started yet
I'm just stalling
oh
what the hell took you so long
shut up and fight
shut up and be my sidekick because I
know who you are now
nice
[Music]
he got Boba fetted right into the
sarlacc pit
[Laughter]
oof yes
I think Jensen Ackles one of the only
voice actors that could also play the
character in real life like of cast like
I could see him oh sure you know what I
mean I would be so psyched I mean we got
soldier boy but we're at the same time
to see him in a right in a non-satirical
universe let him go
step away
taser
Naomi and you'll electrocute both of us
has in mind
oh nice ouch
oh
that's a supernatural blood splatter
tell me what happened to you let me help
you had your chance
it's not too late
it's never too late
people gotta know by now he's got that
mask
but he used his own ninja smoke bomb
against him as he usually uses that
defensively he was like Bob offensive
[Music]
the red blade
test that blood make sure it's who
thinks it is now it's a very convoluted
way in the comic books so I'm very
curious what the movie does to make this
linear
oh Alfred
you want to tell me why this guy ain't
dead we're trying we sent the Fearsome
hand of four
that rolls off the tongue guess they're
gonna need a new name
why hasn't Batman wiped this little
smear off the face of the planet perhaps
he's letting you in the
he could be waiting to take on the
winner
these guys is waiting around
just lining them up can't you feel it
oh
hahaha
blow it up anyway
who knows he's leaving it's gonna be a
sleepover right
I'll pack my toothbrush
and my yellow toothpaste got a brand to
uphold
you need more lights huh don't open it
with a crowbar Bruce have some tact
it's opening with my bird I mean don't
use the weapon that killed him I'm just
saying Bruce loves a little Irish he's
just sub it come on it's gonna bring you
right back out of the ground
is still at rest no
he isn't
that's not flesh
oh my
it's a real doll where are you going to
talk to the man who did
that get the bodies are preserved but it
would not look like just a kid I'm just
saying Batman you look better than the
day you died
a lot of money
a lot of dead meat
[Laughter]
Funyuns
I need you to murder the Red Hood
may I have some water
oh yeah
wowie
I'll need some guys not these guys
because well they're kind of dead black
mask is having the worst day just having
a tough go of being a crime lord it's
not easy I almost feel bad for you
race finds
I am curious what they meant when they
spelled it our Apostrophe a s
oh yeah what did you do to Jason you
remember when we last became embattled
you were planning to blow up Banks
accurative
but you were on to me
I sought a distraction
so I hired the Joker
it was to appear that you had stumbled
upon him
oh yeah he was paid extremely well what
was intended to be a wild goose chase
he murdered the boy
I had hoped to return to you what you
had lost
whoa
I achieved this by bathing in the
rejuvenating Waters of the Lazarus Pier
it has long been rumored that it is
capable of an even greater feat
to raise the Dead
what makes sense with the way it is
named and all it took was a few payoffs
to replace his body
it had unfortunate results
oh cool just dropping a dead kid in the
Lazarus Pit
[Music]
he returned move
but returned
damaged wow
great not great Bob shall I alert the
guards to pursue him don't be foolish
they would never catch him
besides I have done enough
yeah you keep messing up that Rush
I do love that aspect he's like I've
made enough trouble here I might be over
here sorry man ah we lost him
your fault what's a bad miracle
nope he's taken everything I've ever
taught him and turned it on me it's a
hell of my own making Alfred so this is
not your doing you loved him he knows
that it should be enough
not Gonna Make Room for love in that
utility belt no pouch for it that
is
here
this wasn't part of the damn deal you
freak I thought you'd enjoy you think I
care if that scum dies don't know I just
wanted your attention you've always had
my attention
but what I really wanted was an audience
with you
now you have my curiosity sure I had
lots of plans but the end game was
getting better
it took a lot of work to bring about our
reunion reunion have we met before
yes we have that's what I was hinting at
reunion
[Music]
whoa he really was cool with it
oh sweet shot
I've got him
you want him meet me at Crime Alley ooh
his origin versus your origin we're
going all the big spots
what's the plan slumber party charades a
little Truth or Dare yes I'll start with
dare
well maybe I'll just go
[Music]
oh boy oh
I gotta know
who are you
you said we knew one another and you do
seem really familiar
we double at the prom
no I'm just something you helped make
pretty critic
[Music]
ghost of Batman past
unreal Joker got away
this Ends Tonight
all of it
nobody knows that better than me
cool weaponized dumpster that's my
favorite
[Laughter]
oh that's smart
oh
damn
using the cape against him never have a
cape
ow oh that's a cool detail yeah the
Kevlar underneath yeah underneath
oh
yes look at you
Jason
I know what happened oh you got to
talking with race huh or is this just
the real me
damn
oh
what bothers you more at your greatest
failure has returned from the grave or
that I've become a better Batman than
you hey
enough it's over oh
[Music]
I know I failed you but I tried to save
you Jason Bruce I forgive you for not
saving me why on God's Earth
is he still alive
hahaha
Gotta Give the boy points get all the
way back from the dead to me
I thought I'd be the last person you'd
ever let him hurt
a day doesn't go by when I don't think
about subjecting him to every horrendous
torture he's dealt out to others and
then
end him oh so you do think about me
I'm doing it because
he took me away from you I can't
well you won't have a choice
huh if you want to stop me you're gonna
have to kill me you know I won't I'm
gonna blow this derang's brains out
and if you want to stop it you're gonna
have to shoot me right in my face
this is turning out even better than
this
side now do it ham or me decide
oh
foreign
[Laughter]
that's the ultimate joke
oh
oh goody
no don't spoil it
I'm the only one who's gonna get what he
wants tonight yes bang bang boom we all
go out together don't you just love a
happy ending
Gotham is a rough place to live yeah
people just used to explosions
constantly does your home have
decimation insurance
meanwhile The Joker has been returned to
Arkham Asylum officials there claim that
extra measures have been taken to ensure
that another Escape would be impossible
oh good till next time
[Music]
Jason get on out here or I'm going on
Patrol without you
come on Old Man we've got bad guys who
need chasing
this is the best day of my life
huh
oh buddy
damn
what a note to end on
yeah you're right okay Bruce Greenwood
oh Jason Isaacs was Ross struggle got it
and John DiMaggio was the Joker cool
I don't remember Bobo but Gary Cole was
Bobo hey
Bobo is my it's Bobo's my favorite
character I mean who doesn't love so
many fun comic collecting memories of
Bobo so many Bobo graphic novels just
really trade paperbacks that's my next
list best Bobo up here that's the
compendium of all the books
it's a coffee table it's the size of my
coffee
tables I've got you know first edition
Prince of Bobo that's right that collect
uh fine Bobo memorabilia just got back
from Bobo Khan myself this weekend oh
dude I love bobobelia you know it's an
international market but Bobo uh resale
value is is off the charts
yeah that's right man that was great
that was really good yeah yeah like I
was again
I felt did this come out in the theater
like this felt like a theatrical caliber
I think the run time would prohibit that
I guess so uh anything more than like
one of those like oh you know for one
weekend or something yeah Special
engagement Dragon Ball Z I know has like
those one weekend releases or whatever
and like my hero Academia but I don't
know if DC has because it's a lot of
like legalese and stuff but I think run
time's an issue
um they should they could cram this in
like a hundred times yeah I mean they
should these are well worth it
yeah absolutely
they definitely like there's a market
for it too I know so many people that
swear by these movies
uh and a lot of people I think you know
get access to these stories through the
the DC animated films
like I I don't I know these do better
than the comics as far as getting
awareness for stories like this really
well yeah cause like you knew the Red
Hood
um you know before this but I feel like
a lot of people wouldn't have until the
movie because a lot of people don't read
the books so like this would be an
access point
and then they might go back and read the
comics that's why I always think like
these are always great to exist I'm
happy that they make them because yeah
it does seem like again they seem to
have a really good grip on them and
there's so much you know I think beloved
history especially with DC when it comes
to animated you know yeah moving
animation well I think they've earned a
certain amount of like Goodwill where
it's like oh any story they make is
gonna like this is the leveling up like
now people will go read the comic
because it got animated because of the
Goodwill of the animation Universe yeah
and it's like I appreciate that even if
it's not the purest form even if it is
not the comic book it is you know very
much I mean not to slight live-action
movies and stuff sure but yeah it's like
the the halfway point it's the moving
animation it's it's you know they can
take Liberties but also you know I'm
sure it's clearly inspired by you know
iconic cells well and I and I don't
remember uh like I said I've read the
comics since wow uh I think probably the
year it came out like I think I read it
as it was being released so it's been
you know
20 oh God you know over more than 15
years
um but like I don't remember a meso
being in it and I thought that was a
really clever you know to bring in a
character that might not normally get a
a release you know uh now people know
that character and what a great way to
to bring Nightwing in and like to do all
those things so it was really smart like
using continuity and playing around with
mythology and like incorporating those
things oh yeah one I mean Amazo this
would be the first time I am like
knowingly seeing that character so for
me that's yeah that's a bit of an
introduction and uh and two like I
really appreciate the way that yeah you
get Nightwing in here to show to
literally you know embody the alternate
outcome to all of this well and you in
this one movie this is an hour and 15
minutes and they were able to do a
decent job with
black mask Joker Riddler Amazo Red Hood
like the the power of the animation
stuff is if you use these archetypal
characters and and characters you know
like we didn't see anything with Riddler
really but what a great little like side
mission and like Raj al Ghul like we we
know who he is so it works for the
storyline I don't remember which
continuity ended up being the one they
landed on for Red Hood but for some
reason I'm remembering Red Hood as a
character that got brought back through
like uh um like an Earth 2 thing like
there was some cataclysmic event that
shifted that caused him to be able to
come back from the dead but like this
was literally 20 years ago when I read
it so I I don't remember like I might be
mixing up hush in Red Hood but like I'm
trying to remember it wasn't the Lazarus
Pit I don't remember rosh being involved
okay but I could be wrong like I said
it's been it's been long enough that
like I could you know a drinking age has
occurred like I think it's been about 20
years because I was gonna ask then you
know like how does this stack up to the
comic book story and does the comic book
story as you recall it you know I mean
maybe not having racial ghoul but did it
have as many I feel like any Batman ark
or story is going to have multiple
villains showing up and multiple
characters you know of importance aside
from the main focus and the main person
being pursued or whatever
um but this this felt like really well
populated in a way that I don't know
like made me think of the the couple
other of the animated movies I've seen
in the animated show and that you feel
like you have just this this community
of Rogues and characters who are all
kind of just around the corner or in
Arkham Asylum doing their thing yeah and
so at least here I'm I would be curious
to know yeah like who got added in or
who was already there in the source
material to begin with because I I liked
the array of characters they used and
like you said in movies like these are
fun and fascinating to me because it is
a short run time and yet it doesn't feel
rushed and all the characters who show
up feel like they got their you know
they they were honored in the time that
they were there on screen like you said
even the Riddler who's only in one
little side sequence and you know still
feels like that presence you know was
punctuated and I do feel I just looked
up it was 2005. so it's been 18 years
yeah uh which is insane but uh adult
that's adult child someone born the year
this came out can vote yeah don't love
that um but uh to me they Incorporated
those villains really well in the comic
storyline I don't remember it as clearly
I do remember there being like a
greatest hits of villains
um I always thought of Red Hood and hush
as very similar kind of story lines and
I think there's a reason they stand out
like hush to me is kind of like a Now
That's What I Call Batman Rogues because
he's like trying to solve all the
villains to get to the thing and then
this is the other direction this is kind
of the inverse where it's other villains
need to be used to build up Red Hood
yeah so in in hush he's kind of like
chipping away and like and like uh
removing variables whereas Red Hood it's
kind of like showing building up it's
showing the strength of the Red Hood by
him being able to take them out yeah so
what I remember the Red Hood was like
he's so powerful that he's able to
squash blankety blankety blankety blank
and that shows the power of red hood so
while I don't remember the individual
villains I do remember there being like
this guy's awesome because he's taking
everybody out you know what I mean and
he's clearly demonstrating that he knows
through and through the the you know
things that Batman would have imparted
on him over all those years we're
actually working together so yeah you
get this badass who has that one step
ahead kind of uh you know intellect and
special set of skills yeah and who can
also then give Batman a good run for his
money as well you know and this proceeds
Winter Soldier like I I also like that
this is you know a character that is
kind of the the you know Bucky to the
Steve Rogers like this is the character
that comes back from the dead that is
wronged that shows the weakness in all
of his thoughts and abilities and kind
of shows the the Folly in his heroic
Duty yeah oh man you owe a lot to like
winter soldier owes a lot to Red Hood uh
because even like in this this came out
in 2010 uh I think that Winter Soldier
was what 2015. that knife fight in this
they were taking notes
look there was literally a memory stab
stab drop grab might have seen that in a
certain live-action movie starring a
character that's very similar and I
don't know why you're talking I hadn't
seen this until today so I was watching
this like 20
like the choreography at moments and
I've always thought of red hood as uh
kind of the the sins of the father to
the character uh like there's this
really beautiful relationship between
Batman and his Robins as like Batman
lost his family so he builds the bat
family like Batman lost everything that
was family to him except Alfred so he
and Alfred build out this family and who
he couldn't save was the character that
I think is most like him because if you
look at Batman Origin stories like the
year one stuff is always Batman trying
to squash that Vengeance he's he is the
Vengeance he's the Knight but he doesn't
want to kill Jason Todd even says like
would have gone on to do wrong you know
like he's the guy that would have been
if if Batman didn't solve his Vengeance
to a level where he can control himself
that's Jason Todd so I always thought it
was interesting they killed Jason's Todd
so he didn't get to become the evil
Batman so bringing him back it's it's
even more so like I I love the Batman
Joker parallel because it's your one
rule I have no rules Jason Todd is
literally if Batman didn't have the
moral code to develop the one rule it
becomes blank
so he doesn't yeah he doesn't just
become the Joker or something right yeah
he's his own thing and that's why I
think Batman is one of the best
characters in the history of fiction is
he is so multifaceted he has more than
one opposite yeah totally two faces is
opposite Jokers is opposite red hood is
his opposite like he's so archetypal
he's so full of integrity and Pathos and
in like I think and I love you know
Spider-Man Deadpool and all those
characters I think the only truly
Shakespearean fiction character in
comicton is is Batman because he's able
to have so much tragedy and and
Shakespeare's so tragic uh and I'm not
saying that Spider-Man's not tragic like
please don't don't take that for a a
lessening but when you look at
Shakespeare it's a tragic figure and I
think the reason Batman registered with
so many people is that he is so much
Shakespearean that you can re-translate
him in so many different ways like these
great you know powerful sonnets and
plays yeah and that includes his
villains for sure and I mean I really
enjoyed the way this this made me think
of two things one this made me think of
I was watching a a video essay recently
up on the importance of Robin and and
kind of asking why especially the
live-action movies seem very averse to
Robin and and it brought up that idea
that you're talking about whereas you
know like Bruce Wayne learns to you know
cure an aspect of himself that would
lead him down this very dark and toxic
and and you know violent Road and then
is able to yeah
pass that on and create some sort of
hole in bringing on you know a ward whom
he sees you know that potential for both
you know his type of heroics but also
for that you know tragic turn and I love
the way that they Incorporated all that
here but also the way that yeah like you
have this great like I love love love
that came down to this showdown between
Red Hood and Joker and Batman and this
whole thing about
like he you were watching him you know
Traverse and climb the the web and
pyramid of Gotham's crime yeah but then
it all comes down to this really
personal thing and it all comes down to
this overlapping set of plans and you
know you've got like you know the more
uh uh you know you've got the people on
the back foot of that like uh Black Mask
who who think they're in control and
really aren't in control but then you've
got characters like Batman and the Joker
and red hood who are all kind of Chess
piecing around and who are all very
smart and I like the way that the
writing brought both the physical you
know planning to the Forefront of how
brilliant you know these machinations
are but also examined a fair amount of
the themes about you know killing and
why Batman shoes is the kind of morality
he does and I like that they allow even
though you know that they're not going
to agree like Jason uh um Jason Todd
makes good points about how ruling
through fear or you know can be
problematic and you know even though you
know his approach isn't right in trying
to take and control all the crime you're
like well I get this approach though and
especially given the experiences you've
had and the loss that you experienced I
get why you would turn out this way and
so it's like you have this thing that
feels very fitting of you know a story
about this master detective and you know
the people surrounding him but you also
have yeah something that's uh I don't
know it felt very smart and clever
to a degree that is you know that you
want I feel like anytime you're watching
superheroes and villains you want to
feel like there is some kind of master
plan that does take a little bit of
detecting that that does involve you
know intellect and that you want to feel
you know a little bit smart for keeping
up yeah you want to feel clever yeah and
I feel like they did that really well
with all the characters here and then
also took it that extra mile with being
you know pretty emotional and you know
paying off the Resonance of the
relationships and also through the voice
acting like I loved I mean you know I I
feel like obviously Kevin Conroy is like
the gold standard may he rest in peace
but I like Bruce uh I liked uh being
under the green wood with uh Bruce
Greenwood as Batman and I thought uh uh
uh Jensen Ackles was terrific I kept
picturing Jensen ankles which is fun
like I I like halfway through and I was
like he's one of the only voice actors
that could also be Jason's Todd Red Hood
like a lot of I can't picture Bruce
Greenwood as Bruce Wayne no disrespect
Bruce I don't see that whereas Jensen
Ackles I'm like man if they did a live
action Red Hood like love to see him get
to play and his voice is like so
dominant and interesting and I I
definitely think the The Duality between
even like Nightwing and Jason Todd is a
fun thing you could play with and I'd
love to see uh them get into the movies
but and this is going to be people are
gonna be mad at me for saying this I'm
not gonna say it anyway uh I you brought
up a few minutes ago
them wanting Robins in the movies I
think the reason we haven't gotten to
have a robin in the last 10 years of
movies is because they've made in except
for Pattinson but that's because he's a
year one Batman you're two technically
but he's an early Batman I think Ben
Affleck's Batman was too close to Red
Hood okay so if you've got a character
that is already willing to use guns if
you've got a character that's already
willing to kill if you've got then
what's your separation between your
failure as a parent sure like how do you
separate like you need a paternal Batman
in order to make a ward feel like he's
being protected by Family yeah we didn't
develop the Batman in the Batman vs
Superman Universe enough to make him
paternal enough to make him we had the
the prick from fashionable mail from
Mallrats as Batman and he walked around
with that you know arrogance and I love
you guys I'm on record for saying how
great Ben Affleck is is Batman but the
portrayal choice of making him I'm doing
this thing arrogantly is Bruce Wayne the
real Bruce Wayne is very uh broken
um uh he's got a he's a shell of a man
that lashes is out he he doesn't want
this alien to uh take everything that
he's believed in he doesn't want to he's
so protective but it's in a way that
he's uh he's he's a corned animal like I
see Ben Affleck's Bruce Wayne as like
someone who's lost so much he's cornered
that's not someone who could raise a
child that's not someone who could rear
a robin so therefore when Nightwing is
killed or when that Robin's killed and
you see that whole thing I can't picture
a storyline where Ben Affleck could
raise that Robin in a way that he
wouldn't just become red red hood yeah
and then it would be more toxic and
uncomfortable to watch right so like
when Batman's like you know driving his
Batmobile and shooting people you'd like
that guy can't then raise someone like
the lessons taught in this animated
movie couldn't be taught with that
interpretation of Batman I'm not saying
any Batman's right or wrong but the ones
we've seen lately are either too young
or they have you know some some Vendetta
issues a la redhood sure and I mean
there is also the the thing I think
often gets touched upon which is yet an
animated or a comic format it easier to
accept you know like a big grown man and
a kid right running around and I was
thinking that too while I was watching
this is
you know I love a live-action superhero
movie and I love watching the game of
how do we blend fantasy with naturalism
and reality and how do we make it feel
real but watching something like this is
such a joy because you do have that
quintessential Middle Ground to play
with where yeah you have like such
outlandish characters right and a lot of
fantasy uh but at the same time the way
the world Works Blends the two perfectly
it's like you still get the grit and you
still get the darker tones and themes
and they don't feel undercut by things
like humor or outlandish looking
villains or you know even again like uh
someone like Amazon who I'm like who is
this guy kooky name and yeah so like I
feel like there's a beautiful blend to
be appreciated that you can kind of I'm
not gonna say you could only get an
animation but that is very
quintessential to animation and that is
a facet of comics that I kind of miss
and like when I watch Sky High recently
not that this is in any way in that
tonal wheel how house but that movie had
a certain element of
color pop and
I don't know vibrancy or something like
that there's like a sense of fun that
feels very quintessentially comic book
but it feels like we are much too cool
for now yeah and it's like here like I
love to what NPH brought to I thought he
was a really good voice cast choice for
Nightwing but also I really like their
humorous back and forth because then you
do feel like yeah Batman is like the
paternal figure but who's also just
really focused a lot of the time he's
got the compassion but a lot of the time
he's just very much about the cases
about you know the the matter at hand
and then you've got Dick Grayson over
here who's like you couldn't you know
you couldn't help me out over here come
on this is just once just let's go to
the car yeah and it's like you can have
both exist at the same time in this
media and and have it you know feel very
vital in all aspects and I really love
that because it's movies like this or
you go back and watch like mask of the
Phantasm and things like that and you're
like these can be so fun and imaginative
but also you know they can move in and
touch you just like a drama you know
yeah they can invest you that way too
and it's like an the animation I love
the animated awesome like the density of
the story like I don't think you could
make a live action hour movie that would
work do you know what I mean like all
the things you just described plus the
density of it like you know because you
immediately accept black masks look you
don't have to you don't have to write
around it you just go like this is crazy
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then it allows
you you know one big moment of
Supernatural here we're gonna do a
Lazarus Pit right now you know we're
gonna resurrect somebody you know
um bandaged up like a mummy it's like
yeah suspension of disbelief is within
five minutes and as long as the voice
acting is strong enough you don't feel
like it's cheapened like you you're
you're suspension of this belief only
works if everything else is so true and
I feel like really good voice actors
have the ability to to bring you the
humanity even without the eyes yeah and
like I I've been on record like I really
struggle with animation but I'm more and
more trying to you know connect and if
it's this quality like I'm fully
invested like at no point was I like
distracted like I was fully in for that
whole whole journey because the actors
kept me yeah in there and the animators
obviously but I was I was so invested in
these characters no it's everything
because yeah I think it was well written
I like again not having as much of a
reference for the adaptation quality of
the writing I thought it was just well
written in proportion because I've seen
a couple of the animated movies and I
remember watching what was it we saw
that I think the killing joke in the
theaters and there were issues I had
with like how that was uh you know
handled and proportioned and things like
that but yeah this kind of had the sweet
spot for me where I'm like it was fun
it's very imaginative it's got a lot of
Rogues in it but also it has a lot of
the quintessential Batman themes that
are unpacked in a way that feels
satisfying and that feels like you are
getting it more than just ah let's do a
fun Batman adventure yeah and then yeah
you have an intriguing villain and also
you know
anti-potential anti you know you're
sitting here watching this going is
there a chance to reclaim uh Red Hood
it's like yeah you have
so much great animation to sell the
punch of everything and then so much
great voice acting to sell the emotion
of everything and uh and yeah like I
said I loved hearing Jensen Ackles and
I'm very curious now to hear him go on
to play Batman because here hearing him
much earlier it's like watching
Supernatural you know yeah I've heard
his voice age over the years so this is
you know back you know almost 10 years
ago yeah so now I'm like okay this is
definitely younger Jensen Ackles
definitely makes sense for Jace and Todd
and then I know he'll play Bruce Wayne
down the line and I cannot wait uh to
hear that but even uh you know John
DiMaggio I thought was a good Joker yeah
and that's hard to you know have an
animated Batman yeah exactly like I
wasn't listening for Kevin Conrad
Markham that's no easy feat yeah totally
and uh and yeah you know I didn't catch
who played Alfred but Alfred was in the
movie solid
enjoyed him when he was there good
little moments yeah yeah I had a great
time with it yeah likewise man this was
this was a slam dunk for me I'm glad
we're doing more of these because uh
that was that was really fun and I like
didn't know what to expect I just know
the bar is high so whenever people talk
about DC animation I'm like I assume
spectacular so like you know it kept up
to a very high bar of entertainment I
very very consciously didn't reread the
comic but now I'm excited too like I'm
glad I don't get to often go this way my
brain is usually like oh reference
reference and instead now I'm going like
it's been long enough that I don't
remember it well which is nice so I can
watch these movies like fans and then go
and read it after which is what I think
the average person does like I think the
average person gets to see a movie and
then go like oh I wonder what that was
like in the comic so now I'm going to
reread it and have a good time well
that's that's an approach I like to to
borrow something I pulled off C Robert
Cargill once on the podcast he was like
a lot of people try to read Source
material then go watch the movie which
can create a narrowing experience
whereas he said he prefers watching the
thing and then going back for the source
material so it's a more broadening
experience or at least a more you know
uh multi-faceted yeah you're seeing what
the other ideas could be in a way that
engages your imagination rather than
just seeing
made some good stuff check out black
phone uh but I I do think uh that's what
I'll be doing for this DC animated is a
lot of them are from comics from the
early 2000s mid-2000s uh into the 2010s
but all of that is 15 years old or more
so uh while we do these DC animated live
uh watch-alongs I definitely want to
read them after so don't don't expect to
call a comic Corner approach of minutia
breakdown because I wanna I wanna
experience these as you guys do and then
eventually we'll list all the most and
then I'll rank the most accurate after
the fact 2024 when we get through all 87
of these just yell at Greg so he keeps
wanting to make them well guys keep a
lookout for that you wanna you wanna you
got any more thoughts before we close
out I think that's it just uh let us
know what you thought of this leave a
comment if you like us doing these DC
anime if you want to see us watch more
of these because there's a bunch we
haven't seen oh yeah let us know in the
comments which ones uh which ones your
favorite are why you want us to watch
those what you thought of our watch if
this one was uh do you think this is a
worthy adaptation what did you think of
Jensen what did you think of Bruce what
did you think of Joe DiMaggio that's
named Joe dimag is that a baseball team
DiMaggio he was a baseball player wasn't
he I believe so yeah it sounds like a
baseball player if comment below let me
know if Maggio was a baseball player
like this sounds immediately right and
wrong and uh please do like subscribe
hit that notification Bell and send this
to your friends because this needs to
get some views so we can keep doing them
that's how YouTube works all right you
lovelies that is gonna do it you good
citizens of reject Nation we appreciate
you and have a happy holiday we'll see
you soon
thank you